I have a big Disney fans so anytime he
gets to do something you kind of get
some promote not just what you're making
but Disney itself it's kind of a win-win
yeah now it's really great to be I feel
like when you can surround yourself by
positive people who appreciate your work
you just want to give more and that's
why we brought the clip and we flew all
the way out here from Germany that's
good
it's a 5-6 minute clip the Russos put
together and it's you know it's exciting
it's got me excited yeah it shows it
shows that Captain America and all of
the characters have grown in a
completely different light I feel like
now we're starting to get into the realm
of the characters actually being human
beings and being relatable and likeable
so you can see yourselves in the
characters that's what makes it such an
enjoyable experience when you when you
hear the enthusiasm you feel the
positivity you know it's you kind of
realize how many people are impacted by
these movies and it's it's nice you know
I'd be lying if I said it wasn't fun as
an actor you hope your entire career
that you'll find one character that
people can relate to and they like and
they appreciate you for and luckily for
us we got those characters early in our
career with possibly the best studio to
have those characters with the beauty
with marvel is that they continue to
impress they continue to go higher and
higher and exceed your expectations and
eventually you kinda are just so
thankful that you you that this studio
is taking you with them you know you
feel just proud to be a part of the
family no one's career has been stifled
by working with Marvel so when they call
you you answer
you